a shooting at a northwest valley casino
leaves a security officer hurt and now
investigators are trying to determine
what led up to it this happened this
afternoon at santa fe station near
rancho in the 95 and that's where we
find sasha loftis joining us out live
with the very latest
denise and brian this was a really scary
situation for those who were here at
santa fe station today now we spoke with
one man tonight who was right there when
those shots rang out and he tells me
he's just grateful it wasn't worse
a typical day takes a terrifying turn
when shots ring out at santa fe station
right away
dave steele was on the casino floor when
police say a security officer was shot
on thursday afternoon and describes the
absolute chaos inside dealers were
ducking down and the players at the
table brock in the
pits were stuck in police tell us this
all started as some sort of a
disturbance and led to a man shooting
that officer multiple times
it's a situation scarier than many can
imagine but the security officer
survived and the suspect was later
arrested metro lieutenant william mashko
says it could have been much worse they
were able to take
what potentially is a violent suspect
and detain him immediately he credits
the property's entire team for this
quick action that should give citizens a
real sense of comfort to know that in an
establishment like this they are
doing their best to provide for security
as for dave he says he's glad he and his
wife are safe
and hopes more info on this entire
ordeal eventually comes to light i'm not
sure what happened yet i'm curious to
find out
now at last check that security officer
was stable at umc now no word on what
charges the suspect will face in this
situation so far and as of now casino
operations here at santa fe station
appear to be back to normal reporting
live tonight sasha loftis live local now